something else I don't know if you know
this merch because we're going to do a
couple things here before we get into a
movie because I I this is this it's so
busy we're still doing we're gonna get
to the movie really quickly but two
things I wanted it that wanted to we
wanted to do first uh number one is uh
if you are on locals you got your first
hand for your first you were the first
people to be able to grab because I
posted this on locals and it is now on
the Revenge of the sis store
the Steven Crowder
ROTC
smug Club exclusive show fight like hell
with your pregnant wife uh you could buy
that right now and it's for real this
isn't a joke I this is a shirt on our
store there is the link
and uh if you would if you would like to
buy it there you go uh so
damn that's [__] funny fight like
hell with your pregnant wife so merch
you want to set up this next one you
want to set up this next one what's
happening out there in the well well
before we get radio land so here's what
I think Marsh we're about to do a locals
movie riff there's gonna be a lot of new
people today I'm sure that are going to
be joining the locals to watch us Rift
the movie one up which is looks horrible
sucks female Gamers but as if for long
time fans any the worst the movie is the
funnier the Rifts tend to be
so um
but before we we are legally since we're
on Rumble just I immersed I'll break the
fourth wall since we're on Rumble here
and there's some people that work here
we're not going to say who they are
um we are now required
um to play this training video before
any of our riffs or shows so should we
just play it yeah let's just so that
everybody like so everyone gets it she's
not here right well you know what I'll
do he's gonna watch the replay I'm sure
so we'll check it out no he won't that's
ridiculous what am I talking about
um he doesn't pay attention when he's on
the show
um so
guys please sit down um and enjoy this
quick training I want to apologize by
the way because I know virgie's been
gone for a while I apologize for the
lack of kids yelling in the background
yeah yeah yeah don't worry don't worry
don't worry though um first off merge
watch it
[__]
virgie's in here because he's wearing
gloves and giving medicine to my dog
um
you ready guys training video quick
training video before we get into the uh
to the movie here you go
welcome to louder with Crowder new
employee Bible
we know you're all excited to get
started so let's run you through your
first day starting with pre-show
walk Stephen's dog
feed Steven's dog
[Music]
make Steven's tea
important reminder
[Music]
deliver the tea to the studio about five
minutes before run time well you know
important reminder it's almost like he's
unreasonable you know well as we
continue playing this training video it
kind of feels like this is very detailed
and probably not a joke
yeah it almost feels like somebody's
just you know used to work there and
hates it it's almost like somebody used
to work there
it's very possible I don't know if this
is true and
um because this was distributed to us so
we don't know I have no idea we have no
sense it was a DVD it was a DVD
I literally had the rip it from a DVD it
was wild
[__] wild I had to break into an old
I had to break into a Wendy's right I
mean I don't it was VHS wasn't even a
DVD was just a VHS and I had to buy that
converter to VHS to PC thing it was
[__] horrible pain in the ass dude
yeah that's why the tracking's all
[__] up yeah
um so I don't know but it almost feels
like if you pay attention to this video
this is what
Stephen Crowder actually does
and the sparkling water on the left
that's right the water has to be on the
left don't forget that doc Stevens
sometimes Steven wants a potato
guys sometimes he wants what guys you
know you want a good starch guys party
meal guys sometime guys sometimes
Stephen wants a potato
don't you want a potato I don't know
what the problem is
you had a potato and then you [__]
left and it's not working at The Blaze
are you happy
yeah no no
foreign
I'll take my land out fully loaded
please
[Music]
we're live slipping Jimmy
no for 2.5 minutes this is so good this
is so good
that's right
you are
starting to my mind
do Steven's laundry
working there sounds like a [__]
nightmare
work these by the way these are things
that actually they were all made to do
this is 100 True uh and it's it's it's
insane to me right so you're a janitor
you work there and you're a janitor
here's the thing man custodian dick yeah
can you imagine if you went to blaze
think about this right
can you imagine we went over to the
Blaze and like and like Sarah's producer
was walking around and she was mopping
the floor we'd be like what are you what
are you a chant you know what I mean
like that's not your job or your
producer right
yeah it's a little bizarre
[Music]
job
fun to run through
oh good the run through
set up Steven's iPad oh my God
iPad is in studio it's set to do not
disturb it's in inverted dark mode click
the power button three times Tim knows
the super secret password one day you
might learn it too
[Music]
oh
this guy is insane good job posto now on
to the post show
clean Steven's iPad
[Music]
bro I'm sorry I I I I understand having
money but like
can you ever imagine being in a position
where you need someone to clean your
your iPad or your phone like I'll do
that myself you know what I mean like
you are to do it
gloves on when you do it
watch it watch it [__] watch it
that's replaced where's my gun I swear
to God that's my new favorite in my
opinion
[Music]
is this real the information it is for
Real
[Music]
it was funny but the information in this
is all 100 accurate that's really clean
I can see my reflection Steven's gonna
be so proud of you oh my God this is so
good it's so insane
make sure you remember to plug in
Steven's iPad when you're done using it
great job so far Ronnie Coleman
squatting is the best Steven's dog out
to poop that's right
close Stevens blinds
Jesus I
[__] anonymous
congratulations
now you're ready to fight like hell
all that stuff in this video that you
saw and if you're watching this later
probably clipped it's 100 what he does
if you're wondering what kind of person
he is what kind of [__] sociopathic
just Maniac he is
this is it and by the way just just
merch and I have been around the block a
few times I don't know if you ever want
to know what a sociopathic Maniac is you
could have just been a fan of ours five
years ago that's right
listen
Stephen Crowder
this is not just the beginning the first
video the first ring camera video you
saw was a warning shot
that's what you saw because we've done
this long enough where we know
that when you that's that's not
everything right oh but forget that the
[__] video of the wife in him was a
warning shot
that's what I mean that's that's what I
mean that's what I mean that's what I
mean the uh
that was uh the
versus way of telling you
watch it
[__]
watch it and the world is saying back to
you [__] Watcher the Candace Owens
going on there and saying that that that
entire dude we played it on the show
when Stephen went to the hospital and
it's like my heart the blood in my heart
is not pumping right I think you got The
Black Lung pop and everybody had a daily
wires praying for him and it's his whole
thing because he said he needed it then
his wife out to him and goes literally
honestly not everyone because if you go
back and watch that video I broke a ton
of Nightwing last night when you see
Andrew Clayman being like he's fighting
for his life blah blah blah I slowed the
video down to like 25 I tried it I was
telling the fans to send in like a
breakdown of it
um Ben Shapiro was never never bought it
for a moment you can actually well see
his little Jew brain working for for
those that don't know what ended up
happening was it was cosmetic surgery he
had basically what I like to call Kofi
Kingston chest yeah
that happens to a few people like it's
just the way the muscles are they
they're not like they're far apart so it
makes his chest how he has a bird chest
you know so is cosmetic surgery that
whole thing was because Stephen Crowder
what he did was you know when like
cougars get surgery and they say it's
like a procedure like a health procedure
but it's really to get a [__]
facelift
that's what he did he's doing crew he's
doing cougar [__] where can I get an
RTC fight like hell mug well the mug you
know we can make fight like hell fight
like hell pregnant wife mugs too if you
want why not I mean we went whatever you
want I have the overlay thank you taper
I really do
um
I wonder if he's lying about his
fibromyalgia yeah of course he's lying
about his fibromyalgia he's Stephen
Crowder he is now a known liar remember
when he said that she's leaving him
and then it turned out that he hired the
divorce attorney first
that's another line Jeremy boring yeah
boring Jeremy boring there's still
people defending him which blows my mind
Crowder just posted his response on
Twitter we can't man we're doing a movie
review yeah we had to do the movie riff
today we got we're doing a movie riff I
promise you anything that comes out
today
anything that comes out today we will
cover it on Monday